welcome to the tenderloin a neighborhood
in San Francisco Dave Chappelle once
described like this another tend about
that level at all of us it was Robin
that's because this area's infamous for
its drugs poverty and high crime rate
but a San Francisco seeing an influx of
tech workers wealth and a wave of
gentrification is the Tenderloin on the
verge of change to to find out I met up
with del Seymour a longtime Tenderloin
resident I've spent 18 years on these
streets here in all different capacities
from a major drug dealer to a trafficker
so you know these streets really well
hey dizzy del cleaned up his act eight
years ago and he now his neighborhood
tours and works with Co Tenderloin a
project to help young adults get started
in the tech industry good the Tenderloin
itself is a contradiction there are
thousands of homeless people and one in
three adults suffers from severe mental
health issues yet tech companies flocked
here when the city offered them tax
breaks in 2012 that's my buddy we got
300 tech startups upstairs in we works
organization we got Spotify right here
across the street we also have Zeus and
did Zendesk here and we got Zen decks
here so we got over 1,500 to 2,000 tech
workers on this corner Wow just down the
street across from the nearby Twitter
headquarters is a new luxury apartment
complex called Nima where studios rent
for up to $4,500 a month del took us to
the Cadillac Hotel one of about 500
residential hotels with SROs or single
room occupancy units it's government
subsidized housing for low-income
residents
Cathy looper and her husband bought the
Cadillac Hotel in 1976 these SROs are
often the only option in San Francisco
for the nearly 30,000 tenants living in
them like Bob who moved to the city in
the 1950s and lives off his Social
Security checks when I checked in here
it was a rough neighborhood one resident
agreed to show us her room where she
pays 521 dollars a month for rent in
comparison the median rent for a
one-bedroom in SF is now a whopping
$3,600 these are just single rooms that
people live in there's a lot of hotels
here in the Tenderloin with a number of
SROs it's just a room and a bathroom
no kitchen the Tenderloin has tough laws
that protect its SROs from getting shut
down but it doesn't mean they're safe
between 1970 and 2000 as housing prices
went up the city demolished are
converted around 15,000 SRO units what
if a big tech company came to you and
was like we're gonna give you 50 million
dollars to buy this building well you
know it's conceivable that I could
change my mind and my board of directors
could change its mind but it's really
the probability of that happening is
like 1% out of 100 why it's because I'm
dedicated to people like Bob
I mean he's who I work for and he's the
kind of person I want to see in these
hotels Dells not worried about the
sorrows we've come here ten years from
now this table will look exactly like it
looks now why why wouldn't it all of
these are protected buildings can't
touch this building in fact Dell sees
the tech industry as an opportunity I
see the economic integration love and
I'm loving it the commercial and
economic integration now I'm loving it
to death how's it playing out here is
making this this committee no longer
look like Skid Row he's right some of
the change is positive new businesses
have been able to move in to help
revitalize the neighborhood
so we're at equator coffee shop this is
where the Tenderloin meets tech and
what's special about this place is that
they're giving back to the community by
hiring people from the tenderloin
work here yeah this is a store that has
always been the theater 16 it is a
theatre district and it always will be
the theater district some of the nearby
tech companies have even tried giving
back to the community donating computers
to a free local computer lab but is it
enough the only difference between my
girl with the braids selling crack on
the corner and that blonde blue-eyed
girl is chic and Colts the only
difference we need jobs we need HR we
don't need more police we need more HR
because we're gonna be in this job
market we're gonna be we're gonna be
here
detective meat is here to stay so are we